let's touch on on those passenger
numbers uh first of all if we can just
break down for us where we stand
relative to those pre-pandemic Peaks
well we're still currently about 25
below where we were pre-pandemic
actually at the moment that's more like
15 to 20 below because the market has
been recovering
um through the second half of the year
but I think it'll take us until 2025
2026 before we get back to the full
level of demand that we saw before the
pandemic and what's played catch up
quicker leisure travel or business
travel short haul or Long Haul
it's been very much about leisure travel
so what we saw as soon as Markets
started to open in March everyone wanted
to catch up on the holidays they hadn't
been able to have for the last couple of
years so we saw a lot of people going
away for weekend breaks uh holiday
season's very busy and this so the Peaks
have been very busy some peak days have
been as busy as they were pre-pandemic
but outside of those peak times it is
much quieter and that's why we are
encouraging all of the companies that
work at Heathrow to provide services to
scale up back to the full capacity they
had before the pandemic so that we can
meet Peak demand whenever that may come
and let's talk about that balance
because clearly one of the reasons uh
this industry and uh you're part of it
in particular hasn't got closer to
pre-pandemic levels has been the supply
not not not the demand and some of those
limits that you are putting in place on
passenger travel numbers that's that
limit is coming off is it very soon but
but might it have to come back on as we
get to the busy Christmas period
yes if I just give you some context so
before the pandemic about 75 000 people
worked at Heathrow ten percent of them
worked directly for us as the airport
operator and the rest for Airlines and
ground handlers and during the Pandemic
those numbers fell by about 25 000
people so down to about 50 000 this time
last year and what we've been
encouraging people to do and we've been
doing ourselves is to scale up as fast
as we can to get back to full capacity
and what we found before the summer peak
in at the end of June beginning of July
was that the demand was slightly ahead
of where the capacity was at that time
so we've put a cap in place and what
that did was to protect people's
Journeys over the summer so we had 18
million people uh traveling over the
summer service levels actually close to
where they were in 2019 so that's a real
achievement by all of my colleagues here
at Heathrow to serve our passengers but
we're not yet back to where we were
three pandemic so we we have a cap in
place it's coming off uh in the next few
days it actually hasn't affected any
travel over the last few months because
demand has been below the level of the
cap but we think that there may be some
peak days over Christmas and maybe even
into next year where we may have demand
slightly ahead of Supply so we're just
going to have a mechanism in the
background but you won't notice if
you're a traveler that will just make
sure that we can guarantee a smooth
service when you're traveling through
Heathrow I'm not sure John what what
metric allows you to say that service
levels were were as good this summer as
in past years I'm not sure that was all
consumers experience but parked that
issue to the to the side I think it's
fair to say over the summer that
Airlines themselves took the brunt of
the criticism did you feel sorry for
them I get that it's a shared problem
not a Heathrow Airport problem but given
that you had imposed the passenger cap
yourselves
well it was a difficult situation for
everyone and this this is a shared
problem not just a Heathrow actually but
around the world and uh I think every
part of the world has had challenges in
scaling up quickly particularly those
that were worst hit
um by covid restrictions and the UK was
worse hit than
um our competitors in Europe uh but
actually we have worked together with
Airlines and their ground handlers to
build back capacity we have a very
collaborative Approach at the airport
because if you're traveling you don't
care who is providing service you just
want to have a seamless journey and
that's part of my job as the airport
operator to coordinate all of those 400
companies on the airport to give you a
seamless service and to step in if need
be to make sure that we can keep supply
and demand in balance that was a
difficult choice we made before the
summer we had been talking with Airlines
about it beforehand I do feel a lot of
sympathy for Airlines and passengers who
had some disruption when we first
brought the cap in but thereafter
actually we gave very good service
through the summer and the measure I
look at is what passengers are telling
me not just when I'm working in the
terminals myself and people are getting
through check-in and security far
quicker than they expected but also when
I look at the survey results the show
that we were in terms of Passenger
satisfaction very close to the high
levels of service that we saw back in
2019
and and John just finally in terms of
really solving this issue you know
medium and long term is it all down to
being able to find the right the right
staff given understandably that your
industry cut staff during during the
pandemic and building back up has been
harder than the process of of perhaps
letting people off are there any changes
you'd like to see from the government
the authorities to make hiring easier I
mean it's an industry where of course we
want safety first so maybe that makes
that tricky
well you're exactly right it is it's
just a scale challenge we're going from
50 000 people to 75 000 people uh we're
about halfway there at the moment we're
all working super hard you've got to
recruit the right people with a good
service culture you've got to get them
through security clearance to make sure
that they are not a a security risk and
then you've got to train them up in the
specific skills they need many very
skill jobs uh across the airport and it
just takes time to physically do all of
that and no matter how hard you work at
it the one thing government has helped
us with but could help us with more is
on the security clearance side and the
main thing that takes time is validating
people's employment history over the
last five years and if the government
could give us easier access to the hmrc
data records which which has a lot of
the information that we need that would
make it quicker to get through security
clearance and where that helps is that a
lot of people of course are applying for
jobs at other employers other than on
the airport and if they get their their
job being able to start before they've
got the security clearance for Heathrow
then we lose them from the whole process
so we have to start again in recruiting
a good person so cutting down the
security clearance time without losing
any level of security would really help
us